as of february 2021 tesla controlled a
whopping
79 of the ev car market in the us
at this point there's no question that
tesla is going to be one of the biggest
players within the eva industry
most legacy automakers are following
tesla into the ev market
but this is more out of necessity as
opposed to choice
there is one legacy automaker however
who is ahead of the curve and looking to
capitalize on the massive transition
throughout this decade
and that's of course ford so here's why
ford may very well be tesla's biggest
challenger
moving forward starting off one of the
key reasons for tesla's massive success
within the ev industry
is that they are basically the first and
only ones there
legacy automakers have ignored the trend
towards evs
for years thinking that they can easily
make the transition when the time comes
kind of like the tortoise and the hair
similar to the hair though
many of these automakers were caught
sleeping when tesla was quickly
approaching the finish line
some legacy automakers are actually
still refusing to wake up
like toyota but many others are
scrambling to catch up to tesla
and this is really where tesla's
advantage comes from
as legacy automakers rush to improve
their battery technology and start
production of evs
tesla is already in the market selling
hundreds of thousands of evs
every year while ford isn't quite at
that level yet
they're closer to launching significant
evs than anyone else
ford isn't playing softballs when it
comes to their evs
they're electrifying two of their top
sellers including both the mustang
and the ford f-150 the mustang monkey
is directly targeted at the model 3 and
the y and the ford f-150 is directly
targeted at the cyber truck
ford started delivering the maquia in
the first quarter of 2021
and they were able to deliver an
astounding 6614 maquis
in the first quarter alone to put that
into perspective
tesla only delivered 222 model trees
during their first quarter
in terms of their trucks ford is looking
to start deliveries of the f-150
lightning
next spring tesla is looking to start
deliveries of the cyber truck at the end
of this year
but the austin gigafactory in which the
cyber trucks will be built
is still under construction itself so
it's very possible that we don't see
cyber trucks being delivered till spring
or even summer of 2022 either way though
ford is right behind tesla when it comes
to launching a pickup truck
now i'm not trying to knock on tesla
here the model 3 was their first mass
production vehicle
and tesla is literally having to build a
new factory to start cyber truck
production
so it's understandable that we see
production and delivery delays
the point here though is that ford is
hitting the ground running
and it doesn't look like they're
stopping anytime soon
not only is ford one of the first legacy
automakers to launch a significant ev
but they're also being extremely
competitive in terms of price
the closest competitor to the maki is
the model 3
with the maki coming in at 43 000 and
the model 3 coming in at 40
000 you can actually get the maki for
cheaper than the model 3.
because of the 7 500 tax credit that's
only applicable to the maki
that is only a limited time offer though
in terms of performance
the two are basically identical the
model 3 has a 0-60 of 5.3 seconds
while the marquee has a 0-60 of 5.2
seconds
similarly the cars have pretty similar
ranges with the model 3 coming in at 263
miles
and the maki coming in at 230 miles this
same comparison
can be made with f-150 lightning and the
cyber truck as well
the base levels of both vehicles start
at 40 000
with the cyber truck boasting a range of
250 miles plus
an f-150 boasting a range of 230 miles
however there is a possibility that ford
is actually sandbagging their range
estimates
according to marcus brownlee the
estimated range is calculated with 1 000
pounds of cargo
so without the cargo the standard range
may be closer to 350 miles
and the extended range may be closer to
460 miles
now this still doesn't quite match the
cybertron's top range of 500 miles
but these aren't bad numbers by any
means in fact
you may even be able to get greater
range for a smaller price with ford
especially if you're early and able to
redeem the 7 500
tax credit something else to note is
that all f-150 lightning models come
with a dual motor configuration
each of ford's motors aren't as strong
as tesla's but this does give you the
benefit of all-wheel drive
so as you can see ford has done a
splendid job when it comes to matching
tesla in terms of price
and performance and personally i think
that this is the key to winning the
eevee industry
you can talk all you want about how evs
are better for the environment
and why we should switch to sustainable
energy but
money talks way more than humanitarian
efforts the day that electric vehicles
are not only cheaper to maintain
but also cheaper to buy than gas
counterparts it's game over for ice
vehicles
you won't have to go around and convince
your friends and family to switch to
electric
the next time they buy a car they're
going to buy electric whether you like
it
or not with that being said i think ford
is just as close as tesla to making evs
cheaper than
ice vehicles so they're gonna be pretty
well positioned for when that date does
finally come
but we're just getting started with
ford's strengths
aside from already being in the market
and being competitive
ford has an unbelievably strong customer
base americans
love pickup trucks and i mean they love
pickup trucks and ford is hands down the
winner when it comes to american pickup
trucks
the ford f-150 has been the best-selling
truck in america for not one
or two or even five years but 44 years
straight what's even crazier is that the
full f-series lineup is the best-selling
vehicle of any kind in the u.s
period so the cyber truck has absolutely
no chance against the f-150
now this isn't to say that the cyber
truck won't sell well
but the thing to note is that the cyber
truck appeals to a completely different
demographic
i know quite a bit of people with
pre-orders for the cyber truck
and not a single one of them has any use
for the vehicle
itself in my experience the primary
demographic behind the cyber truck are
people with high paying tech jobs
working at tech companies and they're
buying the cyber truck because they
think it looks sick
they have no use for the truck's towing
or payload capacity
the heaviest load they'll put into the
bed of the truck will likely just be a
handful of golf clubs
every weekend so for the most part the
people who actually use pickup trucks
for the utility
aren't that interested in the cyber
truck honestly
i don't think they're even that
interested in the f-150 lightning
either these people love their gas
trucks
and they're not going to switch until
electric trucks are undeniably better
and when that stage does come with the
f-150 lightning on the market
i'm not sure why they wouldn't just
stick with ford like they have been
doing
for the last 44 years the same thing can
be said about ford's explorer and
expedition series as well
americans who love their big trucks and
suvs are likely to just stick with ford
or chevy or ram or whoever they're loyal
to
and that brings me into the next
advantage for ford which is that they
have scalability on their side
all legacy automakers have the advantage
of skill as they're already producing
millions of cars per year
but once again it doesn't look like any
of them are really leveraging this
advantage except for maybe volkswagen
volkswagen however is not that big of a
competitor to ford when it comes to
pickup trucks and suvs
so their transition or lack of
transition doesn't really affect ford
the legacy competitors for ford are
really only gm
and ram it looks like the earliest
washington electric silverado is 2023
and probably 2024. meanwhile the
earliest we'll see a ram pickup truck
is 2024. so ford will have a full year
if not two years to build up production
and deliveries against legacy
competitors
meaning that they'll leverage their
scalability the best but
more than all of this by far the biggest
advantage going for ford
is survival it's no secret that ford
hasn't been doing well financially for
quite some time
even before the pandemic started ford
was losing billions per quarter
but an even bigger problem is their
unbelievably massive debt
on a good year ford is able to profit
five to seven billion dollars
but that's nothing we consider that they
have 160 billion dollars in debt
even if they profited 10 billion dollars
per year it would take 16 years of
throwing everything they make at the
debt
to pay it off and that's not even
considering interest
in terms of american automakers though
ford is the only automaker that has
never gone bankrupt aside from tesla
ford has been around for 100 years
longer than tesla
so i think that's way more impressive
ford has literally survived the banking
plans of the 1900s
the great depression the world wars the
oil crisis
the inflation crisis the rise of foreign
automakers the dot-com bubble the
financial crisis
and the pandemic i highly doubt that the
eevee transition is the shift that's
going to wipe out ford
in fact i think the executives and ford
are looking at the ub transition as a
golden ticket
out of the dead hole and back to
prosperity while the rest of the legacy
automakers slowly transition to evs
ford is going all in they plan to invest
22 billion
into evs by 2025 and 4 billion into avs
by 2023.
to put that into perspective florida
only has a total of 30 billion dollars
in cash
so ford is literally going all in
ford's ceo says that he's confident in
their ev strategy
and that ford won't see it in the future
to anyone
ford is no doubt throwing a hail mary
and i believe that
it's going to pay off some of the best
outcomes come from situations in which a
person
or company has no choice but to succeed
as we've seen with tesla
domino's best buy dell microsoft marvel
spacex
and of course apple all of these
companies have made
unbelievable transitions from their
former selves and i think 10 years from
now
we'll be saying the same thing about
ford now do i think ford will overtake
tesla
well they might overtake tesla in the
pickup and suv markets
but i doubt they'll overtake tesla as a
company
tesla simply has way too many things
going for them outside of just selling
cars
with that being said though i think ford
has an extremely bright future
ahead of them many investors have
started to realize this
and this has led to them beating up fort
stock 70 since just the beginning of
this year
but even with that ford is only worth
59.6 billion dollars
with a modest pe ratio of just 14.83
so if ford really is able to leverage
the ev transition
i wouldn't be surprised to see ford
boasting a valuation of 200 billion
dollars
or more within the next 10 to 15 years
so
if you've been discounting ford you
might want to give the company
a second look after all domino stock
outperformed amazon
apple facebook and google between 2010
and 2018. we may very well see a similar
situation with ford
in the year 2030. do you guys think that
ford can make a transformative comeback
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think that ford is
underrated
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]